bang-bang we're back bill is the third
guest ever to come on off-the-chain
twice
welcome thanks man thanks for having me
again for sure all right
we had epic episode last time there's a
bunch of people who have not listened to
it let's spend kind of 2-3 minutes just
going over your background and kind of
what you're doing with opera and then we
can get into the fun stuff sure so I'm a
long time technology payments banking
guy I've been doing this for almost 30
years
I was doing crypto and crypto mint
cryptography not cryptocurrency it was
at the CIA developing secure messaging
systems back in the late 80s still a
Soviet Union was on the team at Netscape
that deployed our certificate server
product when we created SSL and so I you
know to help develop certificate
authorities even in different countries
when we were trying to do kind of one
dotto ecommerce and then really got the
the payments bug in about 15 years ago
and spent a lot of time in developing
markets trying to build money transfer
products and the ability to use cell
phones and feature phones even to do
money transfer about the crypto bug
about I don't know probably about a year
after the the white paper was released I
read it probably a couple of months
three months later so no really hoards
didn't quite like appreciate how like I
knew that they tried to solve a double
spend problem which I thought was huge
but really is probably about like eight
months later when I was like you know I
think this thing could be huge if this
guy's right were you at the CIA when
you're in it no no that's the a was late
80s I mean this is a long time yeah I
just make it sure because you know I'm
gonna ask if he thought the CIA created
Bitcoin no I don't don't think they as
smart enough people to have created
Bitcoin I actually have very convinced
that Bitcoin was not created by an
academic we can save that for another
okay at the time I think it's just too
much practicality in in in what was done
and
the the anyway another time but but yeah
so like the last kind of eight years or
so I've really been super hardcore in
Bitcoin was mining on a laptop I think
in the very early days that managed to
get get a bunch of Bitcoin that way and
then obviously it was on all of the
early exchanges and I gave the first TED
talk in Bitcoin in 2012 I think it was
at like two or three dollars and and and
that was a huge run up by the way what
was the reception to the TED talk Oh a
lot of people were like I don't really
understand exactly what you're talking
about
but the idea that you can basically have
a bit I kind of liken dit to BitTorrent
where you basically didn't have to trust
anyone that was the way that I could
come up with of explaining a
decentralized system it was like hey you
can't shut bit doors BitTorrent down and
you probably can't shut Bitcoin down and
it was very early then so the reality is
you probably could but the theory is is
that because it's decentralized you
can't shut it down and you know try to
explain it and I there's a mix of Ted in
those days between the VD young and the
old and the old in particular I think it
was like way way like way out there for
them but but hey look the talk is out
there and it's like it's a lot of use
and they're way better introductions now
seven years later you look pretty smart
now yeah well I get a lot of people come
back to me now and said I can't believe
that you know you had the foresight to
actually even want to give that talk
mm-hmm seven years ago and I said just
well for me was just interesting
technology really it was about two years
later after that talk that I had the
idea for even using it to replace
traditional banking systems when I
really dug in and understood multi-sig
and some of the other technologies that
were coming I was starting to dig into
ëthere IAM and the idea of having Tory
complete smart contracts and that all
came later I was just enamored with the
idea that you could have decentralized
money and solved the double spend
problem which you know I was following
digit cash
when I was at Netscape because we had a
relationship with digit cash and and
obviously the the downside of digit cash
was you had to trust did you cash but
the idea of you know using cryptographic
techniques to create money was very
compelling but why bother if you have to
trust someone right to actually create
the money now we're at a point where we
can separate the creation of the money
and the bank
right and have basically two different
kind of crypto based solutions one for
the issuance of money which is where
bitcoin is going and another for the
solution of banking which I'm guessing
will get into you know and how to use
crypto to make banking global well I
like in one to the now and and one to
the verb and and so that now we can
never solve because of this trust issue
we've solved that now or we've proven
that in if we keep going down the path
we're going and we don't f it up we can
we can solve it and that global scale
because not everyone can participate
today and I hope that eventually
everyone can participate this idea of
trusting like the creator of the money
it recently just like smacked me in the
face right we always talk about it but
there was this photo that went somewhat
viral on Twitter
and it's of the ECB Governing Council I
don't know if you saw this I did I see
it described there are 24 people sitting
at a dinner table in a very plush room
that you would expect the elites to be
in right you know a really nice art on
the wall the floor looks like you know
that the carpet it kind of reminded me
of like you ever see the pictures are
like Donald Trump's apartment with the
gold every gold so they're all sitting
there and there are 23 men and one woman
Christina Lagarde I think is the one
woman there's not a person in the
picture that's younger than 60 sure
right and it's the ECB Governing Council
and she posted it saying you know hey
thinks so much to my colleagues for for
you know coming together and us talking
about the Governing Council and how
we're gonna do this etcetera so I took
the photo I said look you can either
trust these 24 people right or you could
trust an algorithm that's transparent
and controlled by no one and I think
it's just such a clear wow this is gonna
be our cake you know 10 15 20 years from
now that we literally were like wait a
minute 24 people decided what happened
to the money yes pretty crazy but I've
also come to understand that we're
trying to solve different problems right
so so but I say we I mean those who
accept the fact that the algorithm is
better like the way your stay away you I
think you mean is is is a different
problem than these central banks the
central banks in my opinion are not
trying to create stable money they're
trying to create stable economies and
they will basically do that at the
expense of the value of your money
right so so they'll create a managed
house of cards like they when we saw in
2007 that hey this house of cards it
isn't necessarily always stable but
their goal is not to say hey let's
preserve poms wealth let's preserve
bills wealth their goal is to get
everybody employed have relatively low
inflation and do that at the expense of
your wealth not not not an addition
preserve your wealth so so their job is
managing economies mm-hm right so that's
why I say I made this point in line I've
been made to point 15 times over the
last ten years is that the value of
Bitcoin is is very stable the value of
the dollar is plummeting and that has
been true forever and that is because
these people manage economies they don't
manage the value of your money actually
they do manage the value of their money
but they're willing to forego that yeah
what will they really team a to manage
the economy yeah there's almost in their
eyes there's a sliding scale the more
that you devalue over a long period of
time then the more you can control the
economy that's right right and the
expansion and contraction the money
supply in kind of the the way that the
system is set up is they really fear the
market Corrections right and so what do
you do is there's a way to keep kicking
the can down the road and you know it's
always their belief that you know five
ten years from now we'll figure out when
we get in that situation right right
exactly now think about this though
right so so if you live to be a hundred
you've seen the value of government
created assets erode probably ninety
percent that's that's the person who
it's most acute to most people don't
appreciate how much government backed or
government created money depreciates in
value because either they don't live
long enough to appreciate it they don't
have enough in the early days of their
life to actually understand what's
happening but what happens when people
start living to be 120 in the West it's
gonna happen it's which is going to
happen look at technology singularity
all this great stuff exponential
technologies which is like you know the
backbone of my life all of a sudden it's
gonna matter that the value of your
assets is being eroded right independent
of your investments I mean if you think
what since 1913 or sitting in 2019 your
ninety-eight percent decrease in
purchasing power of the US dollar
absolutely right yeah it's not like it
was 20% right like never like 98 percent
but again this is their goal their goal
is basically to manage an economy make
they believe this is the only way to get
everyone to work to make everything
affordable mm-hmm right and to create a
quote/unquote level playing field
whatever that means and so is it
sustainable well every every government
created currency has failed eventually
every single one it's simply a matter of
time if you look at the history of bond
markets and war and currency inflation
every currency has failed some more
spectacularly than others some have been
on the way to failing and have been
replaced we saw even the Euro can buckle
because of the you know the
inefficiencies across the different
economies that they have and what one
has to prop up another and I had to
break their own rules in order to save
the euro a few years ago so I think it's
inevitable that every currency
eventually fails the question is how how
long does it take and what happens when
it does right and and so that's the
future of the euro that's the future of
the dollar that's the future of the end
the question is what do we replace it
with and and this really gets at the
idea of kind of the separation of state
and money right which is if every single
currency in history has been revolved
around some governing organization right
where there was self-governance of early
cultures and economies or it became true
governments if they've all failed is
there going to be the separation of
state and money in terms of that the
core unit of account or is this more of
there will be alternative currencies
that have the separation of state and
money but that core unit of account
because the economy is so dependent on
that government control what we kind of
have to have two parallel systems but we
never get rid of the the legacy one well
this is a very long-term question I
think this is a decades-long question I
do think that if I was to predict 25
well certainly 40 years out let's go 40
years out because I think my prediction
is much easier and then when I'll be
dead but - I think I can see this
happening even to the dollar in that
timeframe
nothing like a prediction that only
when you're dead around to explain
myself when it when it when it when it
fails but but no I I actually think that
we're gonna evolve and and and some
people would say devolve to a point
where you actually have competing monies
and traditional Fiat back or Fiat based
money will fail and there'll be lots of
competing monies with interoperability
right across those monies and and so
you'll see not only a Bitcoin but you'll
see money that's more focused on maybe
just payments and which is a little bit
more ephemeral and and so and then
you'll be able to exchange you know
digitally between those currencies and
with on and off ramps when you need to
and and and different technologies will
compete for consumer mind share whether
that's wrapped up in something that we
know is Bitcoin or whether that's used
as a collateral for something that we
might call the dollar I don't know we'll
see but I think traditional government
money's certainly within a multi multi
decade time frame will fail collectively
they will be replaced by something that
is more competitive I remember writing
an outline for a book pre Bitcoin that I
was really considering writing about the
future of money and chapter one was
something about competing Federal
Reserve's meaning have lots of feds and
let them all compete with each other
which is basically what we had when we
had just states all had their own money
absolutely right before there was a
federal dollar absolutely and and
Jefferson talked about the dangers of
centralized federal money even before we
had a central bank and you know that was
the Jefferson Hamilton conversation and
so so anyway I think that the winner
here is going to be the people
eventually but the government's are not
going to go down without a fight and I
don't mean governments going down in a
sense if the government's going to go
away I think the government's value will
be right-sized
over time yeah because when you can't
print money right so you have to
right-size your services mm-hmm right
and and so that's the good news about
all that yeah and to me this get sad
there's a lot of people who've tried to
create change and they've tried to do it
one of two ways either they want to
create kind of a groundswell movement
that says hey the government is too big
or too owner is or not effective not
efficient and all this kind of stuff so
let's apply pressure on the government
and the government
change itself and maybe but that
probably unlikely to is people have
tried to get into the government right
so whether they're representative the
president whoever and they want to quote
quote change something you can agree or
disagree with what they want to change
but that's their strategy is you know if
you're an insider then you can make that
change
but both of those things I think given
the way that our democratic system works
you know if you get into control and
you're there for four to eight years at
some point the next person comes in and
if they disagree they just reverse it
back right and see it's really hard to
create kind of systemic change yeah here
what we're talking about is you actually
go to the crux of the entire system and
you say we are going to change this from
the ground up but we're gonna do it in a
way where you know that the government
one can't stop it but two is you have a
whole network of people who buy into the
idea that in order to change a whole
bunch of things in society and the
economy you have to change the system
right and people basically opt out of
one system into the alternative system
but it's an individual choice to do that
rather than it be a government-led type
initiative now I'm also a big believer
that history leaves Clues there's a path
that's likely to happen and and and if
you travel the world like I do I go to
the Philippines Mexico Argentina
Venezuela and I go to these places and
when you talk to people who are older
they've lived that history you don't
need to go read about it you can just
talk to them they understand they have
lived through multiple currency to
valuations or multiple currency
creations in the case of like the
Argentina Venezuela doesn't Bob
Wainwright or whatever and and these
people generally believe that whatever
their government creates next is going
to fail anyway eventually right so they
say yeah I'll just use a dollar if I can
because it's just gonna take longer to
fail like they don't think that the
dollar is a great currency mm-hmm they
think that the US dollar is a better
let's call it [ __ ] [ __ ] coin go to the
back should coin then all of the others
yep right and may take longer so that in
their lifetime it's less likely to fail
yeah but in someone's lifetime it is
going to fail and that's the difference
and I think that history has shown us
that
you can print your way out of short-term
problems but long-term right different
ball games it's a different ball game
yeah
what um how does banking fit into all
this well but money's the noun banking
is the verb right so so the noun is hey
what is it that basically we're gonna
use as the basis for banking and that's
money and money can take different forms
generally what people assume that when
we talk about banking we're talking
about government's issued money but it
could be anything right what gives it I
actually have always believed what gives
money its value for the most part is the
coercion required to force people to pay
taxes in dollars and to reconcile the
the the the tax bill that you have in
dollars because we could actually create
an economy based purely on cheap if we
wanted to but eventually we'd have to
convert some of that sheet back to
dollars in order to pay our tax bill now
I've talked about this with many many
economists and they think I'm full of
crap when I talk about this because of
the a lot of people who think the
economists are full of crap yeah well
luckily more people are coming around to
to our perspective I think there's less
people kind of moving in that direction
and more people moving in our direction
even if they have a larger loyal loyalty
base right now but but over time you
know like I said I think that you're
going to see this understanding that
competition is better mm-hmm that more
money more types of money is better and
you're going to see a banking system
involved with a new stack back to your
question right and the new stack is
gonna be crypto based all right and what
does that mean crypto based like what
does it actually mean well let's let's
um let me let me give you a general
terms and then we can put it in
advertising lately the announcement of
the Apple card I've been testing that
it's a really cool product I love how
it's integrated with mobile there was
announcement this week when we're
recording this with Citi partnering with
Google into banking checking now what's
interesting about that is is that I want
two things in my opinion one is crypto
specific but one is every major tech
company is going to get into banking in
some way I agree with and and they'll do
it for specific to their audience the
the way Apple did it and the way Google
did it should be very indicative to put
somebody paying attention of how their
user bases are different
right Apple focused very on very
high-end experience around a titanium
looking card with a really high spending
limits that only focus on integration
with Apple pay in a very high-quality
way that would focus on the probably
more of the wealthy and its credit and
and its credit on the back it's a big
silver Goldman Sachs on the logo right
so that that should all tell you about
who they're catering to with that
product
Google's announcement focused more on
the DDA the actual savings account which
really I think should tell you that very
user base in the u.s. is a little bit
more kind of straight up middle-class
and they want to tie that Android phone
to to that account now when I look at
both of those announcements the company
that I think should be most worried on
the planet about those announcements in
my opinion is Samsung because Samsung
actually is the one that actually
competes the most with Google from
mindshare right because it's the pixel
versus it's not really people making a
decision about Apple versus a galaxy
it's usually galaxy versus a pixel yeah
it's like Apple has what I think it's
like 14 percent market share or
something you know Google has or Android
has you know 80 plus percent and so once
you get into the bucket of I'm gonna buy
an Android then it's which phone do
exactly exactly it's it's it's Apple
Apple is focuses experience in margin
right they put a margin on their
experience in a dental budge from that
target whereas in the case of Samsung
there's like hey our market globally is
wildly fragmented meaning we have a
massive customer base in every country
you know we can't do easily what Google
just did and have it actually solve a
problem for us because we have to deal
with 75 countries am I going to put 75
banking partners in place in 75
countries to create savings accounts
yeah I could but if I had a single
solution that actually did that for me
that would be really interesting well
that's what crypto does for us you could
actually create the equivalent of DDA's
using smart contracts right that solved
the same problem where the legal issues
become one of crypto custody versus
traditional banking you can we've even
shown through some of your
other guests that we can actually pay
interest on those accounts yeah right so
this is where I think APRA is going so
okay so let's talk a little bit about
what you've built so far and then we can
talk about kind of the future sure
describe kind of what was the original
idea for the company so so the original
idea came when I was looking at the
money transfer space where I was
spending a lot of time I'd created a
non-profit in Haiti after the earthquake
they were literally helicoptering money
and it's crazy
have you seen the pictures of it I was
there dude it is but he was always wild
right and so it's like pallets of cash
just coming in through helicopters
picture a helicopter like in Vietnam
Vietnam videos that would be bringing in
supplies those supplies like like when a
huge crates in this case that's money
right because Western Union outlets were
destroyed
banks were destroyed but the island gets
or that half of the island of Haiti gets
30% plus of its GDP from taxi drivers in
the US you know from from other you know
people working in cleaning and other
kind of service oriented jobs in the
u.s. 30 percent so so one you had
everything was destroyed plus the money
couldn't come in because we couldn't pay
it out yep the officials in there anyway
so I spent a lot of time in the money
transfer space in Haiti Mexico is that
is that considered money transferring
when they helicopter the money in I
remember that's how I actually met a lot
of friends did I have today from the
State Department who were working with
the army to help solve this problem and
you want to talk about centralized it's
my god see so the one other story that I
have that's similar to this is after
Hurricane Katrina in Louisiana some of
the guys I was in the military with they
got called to go down there and they
thought you know we're gonna go pull
people out of their homes and kind of
the things you would expect that the
military shows up in those scenarios and
I'm not talking about the guys he goes
oh no dude I was walking around Walmart
with my m4 and I said what and he goes
yeah because the armored trucks couldn't
actually come and pick up all the cash
so he said what people didn't realize
was we had you know two three four or
five million dollars sitting in the back
and we were literally armed guards to
guard the cash because all the systems
were down the infrastructure
Petra and I just remember sitting there
thinking like we can think we're the
most connected you know technology
advanced civilization in the world the
power goes out game over right we go
right back to the archaic that was that
TV show revolutions from the degress but
I remember that show it was super cool
what happens when the power goes out
pretty much for good I haven't seen now
it was so good back to the the first
season was awesome then it went downhill
but liked it was basically your back to
the to the stone Age's or like within a
few weeks
mm-hmm right oh yeah and ironically it
was a science fiction show because it
actually tells you find out later why
the power went out I know it's all
science fiction related in any way okay
so so today Abra is a super easy to use
global crypto wallet that allows you to
store dozens of different crypto
currencies in the US you can use your
bank account to add money to the app
this week we announced that we
dramatically increased our banking
limits so I think you can do something
like four thousand dollars a transaction
and like eight thousand dollars a week
in deposits you can use your Amex car
and your credit card to all to buy
Bitcoin or any other cryptocurrency you
can we support all the major stable
coins now everything from tether to pax
to true USD we're launching died once
they finish their upgrade in a few weeks
all you know within the app app and you
can easily with one button click
exchange between those currencies and
and we we had a mandate in the company
we wanted to create an experience which
was more like travel X at the airports
than a trading app so you don't see any
fancy ordering in the app there's no
limiting stop orders you want you want
to take you're looking at my app right
now you want to take some some stellar
lumens and you want to convert them to
Bitcoin you press exchange it tells you
which currency you want to go from which
currency you want to go to how much and
you're done yeah it's basically that
there's a very big bifurcation in the
market right there's kind of the
advanced traders who are they need to
stop limits that you know they're very
precise in their pricing and hey I got a
hit that you know exact put you know
type order and and all that kind of
stuff your user base is hey I want to
buy some Bitcoin I want to buy some
stellar I want to buy you know I want to
do something that is fairly
straightforward
super simple I don't need the advanced
trading function correct and we also
have a lot of people who want to use
this stuff to send money so we have some
users who use abre to to buy like their
Bitcoin their ether their ripple there's
their their their lumens and then we
have some people who will send it and
that's the the history of Abra was was
that I was interested in figuring out a
way of using Bitcoin as the basis for
doing money transfer globally and I had
to cite it created this idea of the the
synthetic assets which was basically a
Bitcoin backed or Bitcoin collateralized
dollar or Bitcoin collateralized peso
and how does that work right so a
Bitcoin backed dollar yeah so the way it
works we don't have much of that going
on in the app anymore most of the assets
have been since ported to because of all
the stable coins that are out there we
don't we didn't need that but it really
helped abra out of the gates to be able
to offer services quickly the way it
worked was we had these multi-sig
contracts multi-sig is a technology in
Bitcoin that allows multiple parties to
sign a transaction as opposed to just
one party so you can create a wallet
where I can only move money if two
different parties sign the transaction
there's three of us that all have rights
to it but two out of the three of us had
to agree to do it right thinking any
combination of that you could have like
six out of eight have to sign or
whatever it's very clever and so we use
that technology to basically create
contracts that would say okay if the
price of Bitcoin goes up and you're
trying to hold dollars you're now
holding too much Bitcoin and we would
actually take away some of your Bitcoin
if the price of what Bitcoin went down
and you're holding dollars you actually
not holding enough Bitcoin so we would
actually give you more Bitcoin so the
the value of what you're holding in
dollars would be stable and it would be
the mistress thing that would fluctuate
and we did that to the tune of like over
a billion dollars in volume so we I
think ran the first truly successful
global test of a synthetic asset based
on Bitcoin and it was all based on
pickle we did a little bit of like coin
testing when the system had issues when
when the the mining fees skyrocketed
because all those transactions were on
chain which was also crazy and like go
and helped us with that because when
when when the mining fees for
multi-state transactions hit $40 they
were only a couple of dollars with with
Lakeland in like Lane is more or less
the same thing when it comes to
multi-sig and the scripting language so
basically you're using Bitcoin rails to
transfer dollars that's right as a way
to look that's right and that for us was
originally meant to solve a money
transfer use case back to your original
question and we've since kind of morphed
this into a really long term banking
play where the first use case was about
investing so users in the US are able to
buy crypto there's about 60 currencies
in the app crypto currencies and then
outside the US they we have a stock
investing feature we're actually going
to become a broker dealer now in the US
so the next year you'll be able to do
that in the US you'd be able to buy
stocks and and you know you can
basically load your money in in the
Philippines and pesos for example and
convert that to crypto you can convert
it to Apple shares you can convert it to
Google shares or you can convert it to
Manero right and you can take your
mineiro and convert that back to pesos
or you could take your Manero and
convert it to Apple shares all right so
so we want to bring those capabilities
to the US and have a global app that
that does all of that and then the next
steps for us will really push us more
and more towards being that global bank
more payments capabilities more money
transfer capabilities we try not to do
anything that's not global in other
words if I enable you pump to transfer
money to somebody here in New York you
should also be able to transfer money in
our app to the UK to Germany to France
to Australia to anybody with anybody
right and we have lots of users who
figured that out in the app today we
want to make that way easier for people
who really aren't necessarily into
crypto but take advantage of the crypto
back to the point about Google versus
Samsung Google is gonna have to repeat
that partnership in a hundred countries
in order to match their user base
globally yeah we can do that out of the
gate with crypto and not have to put
those partnerships in place except the
rails to get money out of the existing
system yeah and what you're really
talking about here is all of the
regulation right this is probably one of
the most misunderstood things by people
who are just coming into the ecosystem
is there are two separate systems right
there's the Fiat banking world and kind
of Fiat financial system and then there
is the crypto native system and really
where the regulations become onerous
it's not in either one of those separate
systems it's when you try to go between
them
so you want to take US dollars and turn
it into Bitcoin regulators that what are
you doing right and and you're gonna
have a lot of hurdles to jump over or
reverse I want to take Bitcoin and go
into dollars
what are you doing a lot of hurdles but
if you for example mine Bitcoin and then
want to use it within a crypto native
system and you don't ever want to go
from Bitcoin to back to the legacy world
it's actually not that owners right it
allows you over 50% of our deposits
right now our crypto the rest are are
people coming in through the banking
system and we're committed to both now
at scale more people will probably come
in upfront through the banking system
but we're giving people crypto rails now
because we have a lot of awareness for
what we're doing in the crypto space but
we need to grow APRA right and so the
way to do that is to go to every country
in the world and actually say all right
I'm gonna make it easy for you to get
money out of your bank account or like
we're doing in for example in the
Philippines we've made it easy for you
to go from cash to Bitcoin we run the
most successful like in country cash
network in the world for converting
pesos to Bitcoin how does it work
you walk into any 7-eleven or any pawn
shop or any remittance outlet in the
country and you basically say hey I want
to basic I want to load pesos into my
abre app unbeknownst to you what you're
actually doing is buying Bitcoin mm-hmm
right and then there's Bitcoin are
basically converted into whatever you
want to hold on the phone using the
process I described before yep and we've
done that and that's a process and user
experience they're used to doing they're
used to doing it because they do it for
remittances they do it for bill payments
it's just very common in the country to
deal with cash and so because all of
these stores have a presides in them the
awareness for abra in the philippines is
very very high and so what we've
realized is from a marketing perspective
there's actually an advantage to being
able to provide those ramps because it
helps you to get the same time to create
brand awareness if you're solving
specific problems so we had people who
we have people in Philippines are doing
that just to invest in Bitcoin we have
people who are doing that to send money
we have people who are doing that to
bypass the banking system there's all
myriad reasons why people are taking
their cash walking into a 7-eleven and
converting it to to Bitcoin the bottom
line is is it works and it works really
well now we also have a lot of people in
the same country who will use the
banking system
to get money into Abra or Bitcoin so we
literally have three different ways in
that country right we're coming in
people are coming in now in the u.s.
it's like 80 percent bank and 20 percent
Bitcoin but they could come in via cash
if they have a friend who that who you
know they want a hand cash to who who
owns Bitcoin and we have people who tell
me that they do that as well right I
used local bitcoins to get money into
Abra for example right now we we were
not integrated they just do it on their
own and so once people get money in
where do you think this goes right so
you've kind of built some functionality
now that it's very obvious in terms of
the value that it brings but like how
does this evolve over time
yeah I I think I think Abra evolves to
become the killer banking play globally
I think what happens that is a bold
statement I love it that's why I love
talking to Bill yes so so I look at
what's happening right now with the
likes of Apple pay Google's announcement
all the Challenger banks out there I've
got a list that I track of about a
hundred challenger banks I mean there's
a lot of companies trying to kill banks
or change banking all of the
technologists are assaulting Wall Street
yeah but that all these banking plays
are basically doing the same thing as
the banks themselves they're partnering
with banks that using the same core
banking systems they just operate faster
because their startups they're there
they're limber the more nimble they have
streamlined compliance systems it's all
basically about in my opinion these
better user experience
slicker design that's right some kind of
marketing gimmick I'm front-end to
incentivize you to come in and things
that are used to incentivize growth but
in the steady state are unsustainable
right really high interest rates and all
that kind of thats not what i mean i
mean if you want software to eat banking
it's got to do it from the inside out
not just from the outside in right now
we're focused on the outside in I want
to do it from the inside out which
basically says let's build crypto based
rails so that every service we launch
can be global I can do deposits I can do
interest payments I can do lending I can
do even card payments all basically
using crypto rails in a way that makes
it easy and transparent to the average
user so whether I'm sending dollars in
the US two pounds in the UK or making a
pound base card payment or using those
pounds to buy crypto it's all basically
using a single global system
that is perfectly legal in every country
provides the rails to get in and out of
that system right so this is where our
Abra is laying the foundations to build
that global bank now right and and we
want people who we want to make it
useful as we go right so all everybody
uses a / to buy crypto today doesn't
necessarily do it because they believe
in the long term vision of course they
doing it because it makes it easy to buy
crypto today get the money in and out of
my bank account send money if I have to
send money to somebody else and we're
gonna keep adding value along the way
even try to get to profitability in the
next step but continue building on that
vision to become a massive global bank
all right so a couple of tangentially
related things that I'm generally
interested in your thoughts first is
when I was at Facebook one of the things
that we probably underestimated our
advantage but since I've left has become
very apparent to me is a company like
Facebook has now they're probably over
80 million small medium-sized businesses
so these SM B's and so if you think of
them as kind of like retailers right if
you were to roll out a point-of-sale
system or some sort of payments type
product it's really a marketplace where
you've got users who are the payers or
the purchasers in that transaction and
they've got people who can receive it I
think a lot of the technology companies
focus on the consumer right like that
that purchaser having the user base of
the businesses already there and being
able to incentivize them to adopt and
things like that can be helpful do you
think that in order for kind of this
global crypto based banking system that
you're talking about do you think that
it's dependent on the adoption by the
retailer or do you think that you get
the consumers the consumers are
demanding it and then the retailers are
basically forced to start accepting okay
let's break that down so so let's talk
about the existing systems then talk
about Facebook and then I think where I
think it's really going today the
existing solutions assume that the
banking rails are in place right card
networks basically assume by and large
that the the network the social network
of connecting consumers to each other
connecting consumers to merchants is
facilitated by the banks and they act as
a network that can
the dots like the Internet is a network
of networks that's what the internet is
card networks are a network of networks
where the networks are the banks okay it
doesn't have to be that way Facebook has
just showed us that right so the next
step is to say can we replace the keep
the card networks in place right and
replace the banks with something else I
actually I actually think if if it was
just as easy to settle with a stable
coin the card network the card networks
would gladly do it what do they care as
long as as a matter of fact the more
middlemen they can eliminate in the
transaction or for them the better for
them right so that's gonna happen in my
opinion all right especially in places
where they have less the banks have less
power within within the big four
networks globally so expect that to
happen internationally in the next 24
months III would bet any amount of money
you start to see stable coin based
settlement for card products which
completely bypass the banks now let's
relate that to the networks themselves
well the the networks are the ones most
threatened by the social a social
networks getting into payments yep right
because they're the ones that actually
have created via brute force the social
network fabric that enables payments to
happen today Facebook did it in less
than ten years right at a fraction of
the cost in today's dollars and can
basically overlay payments on that
because they have distribution
absolutely between consumers and
consumers which is the Libre vision or
business and consumers right which they
can easily do with their money transfer
licenses and they're starting to do this
kind of like the thing about Facebook
specifically is pretty interesting is
they actually have to plays in the
payment space they have the crypto play
which is Libre in the Calibra wallet etc
and then they recently have started
touting more and more the Facebook pay
which is send fiat money in the regular
world you know kind of legacy world
across all of our apps and products
that's the short-term practical way to
make money using this it's like a long
long term strategy in a short term trade
right now they could have easily built
Libre by the way using that model right
but I actually think it's interesting
that they chose to take a much more
complex approach which long term
separates again that now from the verb
to say okay let's separate the money
from the actual banking services we want
to provide I think that they made it way
too complicated for themselves and could
have made it much
year out of the gate but whatever I do
think that if I'm Visa Mastercard Amex
little less so cuz they're closed-loop
but if I'm looking at this whole
universe the company that probably
scares me the most right now is Facebook
right even more so than Apple and Google
because they have that connectivity
tissue between their users that they
created over multiple decades right and
can easily overlay payments on that and
incentivize people to use it and people
think all people aren't gonna trust
Facebook and that's a bunch of crap
they're right the average user isn't
paying attention to this discussion of
Cambridge analytic and this trust at
that trust they just don't care not only
in the u.s. is that true but it's
definitely true globally you globally
they're growing like crazy when I when I
was there I won't show the exact use of
the country and kind of what we were
doing cetera but but basically from a
structural standpoint Facebook had grown
so rapidly that we were literally
running out of people to bring onto
Facebook right like people with internet
connectivity where there was not very
many why they're trying to get into the
business of providing the connectivity
so we only way they can grow we into the
I think it's 2014-2015 launched internet
or aggress was we're gonna go give the
Internet to everyone and people hated
the idea that Google that that Facebook
would or Google would provide services
like that because Google is doing the
same thing because then they would only
use your relationship and I'm like well
wait a minute if they're gonna spend
their own money to solve this problem
let them do it
we had it's something called Facebook
light they get the names wrong but I
think that's what it was and basically
what it was it was zero rated which for
all intensive purposes means people
could use it for free and there was a
deal that got done where it got
preloaded on hardware so if you went and
let's say you were in Ghana or Nigeria
you know something like that and you
bought one of these phones it came
preloaded with Facebook light and in
some countries there was actually eight
applications that it came with one of
them was Wikipedia one was you know I
think a Women's Health Facebook etc and
I remember the results came back from I
can user study and multiple people in
there in some form or fashion said Mark
Zuckerberg created the Internet
and it was this feeling of I accessed
the internet through this portal this
portal was created by Mark Zuckerberg
and Facebook so Mark Zuckerberg created
the Internet and I remember thinking to
myself one that's wild if you say that
the Western world right people like how
could you believe that but two is if you
think that those people care about
Cambridge analytic or the meddling in
the electorate they're not one not even
aware of it let alone two even if they
did it all they're saying is what
happens in every country that's right
what do you mean most countries it's
legal to be a politician in a lobbyist
so you know it's only like in the US and
Europe where or maybe Australia where
Canada where we basically have this kind
of you know unique vision on how the
rest of the world should work visa vie
our own well and it brings me back to
this idea of it and I think what you're
hitting around here is the connectivity
right and so I have pretty strong views
I think in terms of there are two things
that should be open and permissionless
in the world right that's information
and money so the the movement of those
two things is really important that we
incentivize that to be as free-flowing
as possible right there's other things
like stocks and bonds it kind of the
regulated financial system etc I'm
actually much more comfortable with that
not being in a free open permissionless
system but but we can all right we could
debate it as a right but and it's more
of uh I don't think regulators will
allow people to transact securities back
and forth without them being able to
step in and say timeout right first yeah
but but for sure money and information
like you would have to spend a lot of
time to convince me otherwise I
shouldn't be open in frame well Facebook
solved the information one right and it
basically said look now it's not is it
truly open and permissionless no but
it's probably the best thing we have so
far right in terms of staying connected
to people around the world communicating
in multiple formats and different
multimedia you know formats etc and so
why can't they do money right it's not
that big of a change if you're on
facebook Messenger and I send you a
message versus I press a button I send
you money yeah there's a little bit of
difference there but it's not much right
the difference between Facebook and visa
is visa connects to the banks
and Facebook is basically gonna just
connect to a stored value whether that
stored value is Libra or something they
create that centralized ultimately it's
going to work or Bitcoin or Bitcoin
that's lutely and and I actually think
come on David come on man no these guys
they're really good guys and I I've
spent a lot of time with them and I
actually think that their biggest fear
when it came to Bitcoin was what happens
if we turn on a hundred thousand even a
hundred thousand they have billions if
we turn on a hundred thousand whatsapp
users who immediately within minutes
starts spending money on sending money
in our app what's gonna happen to the
Bitcoin rails yeah and they basically
came to the conclusion that bitcoins
gonna go to a hundred thousand and
mining fees are going to hit $75 and
this is not gonna work for the kind of
remittances that we want to do and they
wanted to do this relatively quickly and
even though even though people are
saying hey this Libre thing is gonna
take years even if it takes two or three
years that's still relatively quickly
relative to the internet and so they
need this to work now in their mind and
I think there was some some
consternation that Bitcoin wouldn't be
able to scale even visa be lightning to
do the kinds of transactions they want
to do yeah it's very important right you
know you and I both know the same people
there and I always am careful to caveat
the conversation with these people are
very pro Bitcoin right and and they
learn that I know actually are holding a
big claim personally and we're very
early yet bought in size they believe
etc but what they believe is today it
serves more as a store of value and what
they really want is they want a payment
right ass Avenue payments are ephemeral
from a consumers perspective meaning
that how it goes from me to them and
what happens in between is it's kind of
gone in a fleeting moment and I don't
really care as long as it works and I
trust that it's gonna arrive right
people my money transfer days people
would say I hate that I have to trust
Western Union but I do right and I'll
gladly pay up the you know 10% in FX and
transaction fees that I have to pay to
send money because I simply know it's
going to get there right now the reality
is they don't have to pay 10 percent in
fees for the money to get there even
without Bitcoin right they can pay a
fraction of that but they continue to do
that because they trust that the money's
going to arrive of course so I think
that Facebook will
yet a certain amount of users doing
things because they trust that when they
use whatsapp it works when they use
Instagram it works and that's why
they're going to start creating branding
that makes people clear that when
they're using Instagram they're using a
Facebook product so that when they send
money from Instagram to whatsapp they
know that that's actually going to
arrive because it's all Facebook at the
end of the day so it comes in identity
management play here's the the unpopular
opinion or kind of the contrarian view
of the Western world people trust
Facebook more than they trust the banks
even in the West we look we do NPS and
Net Promoter Score analysis on our own
user base all the time we have very high
MPs at Abra it's on the order of like 60
60 65 percent that's pretty high very
high now we there are banks in the US
that have negative NPS scores now let's
let's understand what a negative NPS
score means that means you spend money
to acquire a customer and that customer
actually detracts value on a net basis
from your entire user base because they
hate your product so much after you've
acquired them so so they're the least
trusted industry on a brand basis right
right is basically if you they do you
know media banking etc and every year
year after year it's the banks are the
least all the other organization that
would have as low an NPS score would be
Congress if you could figure out how to
create one for forty US Congress like
right I'm not kidding there are
literally are banks that have a net
negative NPS score so Facebook's NPS
score is obviously not negative right so
it's higher than the banks by definition
and they have a much bigger user base
globally than Visa and MasterCard
probably combined right so so at that
but maybe even Amex and you combine two
three like if ace books network is
bigger period right so obviously right
for them to get into banking means
getting into payments back to your
earlier comment getting into Merchant
payments it's all the same thing as you
think about building kind of this Bank
of the future right if you will and in
the bank being crypto native do you
worry about those large technology
companies coming in and I don't mean
this in a negative way to them but just
kind of like one foot in one foot out
right so they kind of have multiple you
know kind of
pieces on the chessboard right so
they've got a crypto play they've got
kind of a legacy play maybe they'll have
two or three other plays that they kind
of put out there and they're really
they're pushing full speed on all of
them but they're trying to figure out
which one is gonna be the one that they
can you know double and triple down on
shore do you worry about kind of that
type of competitor if you will or do you
think that you've really got to commit
to crypto native and that's the future
and kind of that's where we end up and
so having all of your resources
dedicated to that ends up being the most
advantageous thing well I worry about
Abra and I worry about adding value
today right so that's what I focus on I
can't focus on what anybody else is
doing except for myself I do spend a lot
of time looking at what I think I'm
replacing right meaning if I have a user
who's using a bird by crypto is this the
first time they're doing it or am i
replacing something else and it's a mix
I'd say the vast majority are using Abra
as first-time users or if they got
Bitcoin somewhere else it was a
standalone Bitcoin app and they're
moving into something that gives them
access to lots of coins or maybe they
want to use the Bitcoin for money
transfer and they're doing that for the
first time because I can send Bitcoin to
somebody who receives pesos or more
dollars for example and Avril makes that
very easy so so we think about it in
that context and we simply want to add
more value as we go and we know that if
we're nimble and fast and we execute
really well in the user experience which
is our bread and butter that we will
continue to grow as a company and that's
what I focus on I can't [ __ ] I can't
spend my time worrying about what 17
other companies are doing to execute
because if our history has already shown
us that when we execute well the users
will actually use the product and more
importantly they'll talk about it to
their friends without me having to pay
them oodles of dollars to talk about it
well and part of this user experience
advantage if you will right is for those
that have not built technology products
before one of the the cheap tricks if
you will if you want to increase growth
increase engagement etc you can do
simple things like make the page load
faster right like like like people don't
think about it but there's test after
test companies I've worked at I've come
as I've built and obviously copies we've
invested in where if the page loads in
two seconds versus half a second the
half a second can drive much more
engaging it much more growth etc and so
you can get things through performance
wins right that drive
but you also can get things through
simply hey it now takes you two clicks
to buy Bitcoin rather than it being four
clicks yeah and so that user experience
I don't think that people put a lot of
weight on it when you talk about it cuz
it's such a qualitative thing where you
can't really quantify what is the user
experience but when you look at data you
can really tell the difference and it's
been something that you guys have kind
of hung your hat on in terms of being
able to use that to it as an advantage
we track every click now we don't know
that it was pump that clicked here that
we know a user clicked here we know that
a certain number of users clicked here
and didn't finish like for example if I
want to load money B my bank account we
know that for example X percent of our
users every day start that process and
don't finish and so we're constantly
like an aggregated anonymous anonymous
information and we say ok how can we
improve this process so we'll send out
surveys and ask users are you willing to
talk to us about your experience with
abra and a certain percentage are
because they're very passionate users
and so that goes into iterating
constantly on what we call improving the
funnel the funnel basically says ok I
have a certain percentage of users we've
had we've had over a million downloads
of the abra app now which is a lot and
the critics fear right and and and we
have you know six figures of active
users every month and again this isn't
trading right this is you know a much
stickier retail kind of user so so we
dig in with them like I'm looking at our
app right now if I take my thumb and I
pull down from the top of the screen I
see a little scroll wheel that actually
updates the entire portfolio we have
users who log into the app all day to do
that because it's the simple easy non
trader way to track prices and they just
open up the app scroll down with their
thumb and they say I love doing that I
love doing that every couple hours
it's the dopamine hit dopamine hit
exactly and so you know we had a charts
function in the app it was kind of
mediocre we ripped it out a couple of
weeks we're launching a new one it's
it's not meant for the trader it's meant
for the easy-like retail consumer to
look at the Bitcoin price or the stellar
price or the ripple price and say oh I
get it it's moving it's trending in this
direction I'm gonna buy that's it so
this brings me to one of the areas I've
started to think more about right which
is you've come at the bank of the future
if you call it right from a wallet first
retail user
acquire an asset send and receive right
is kind of the core functionality of
what you built you built a great product
that obviously people have been very
attracted to it's grown very quickly and
I think one of the key differentiators
for you is and they keep coming back
right so so you've both this really
great ecosystem if you flip it on the
other side there's another group of
people who are going after the same
opportunity I don't think that you're
directly competitive with them but their
strategy has been build an exchange
right right so go after the trader look
for volume and liquidity and then once
you have that then start to build out
services etc today most of those
services actually have been more trader
centric so futures and all that kind of
stuff I think that they're starting to
tip their hand a little bit and say hey
like they may get into some of the
banking services etc how do you see
going after that same opportunity is it
a thing where they're gonna have to come
in to the wall they're you know many of
them acquired wallets etc or is it
something where a wallet you then expect
over the future you can add some of that
more trader centric type functionality
and it gets you to the same kind of end
result that's a great question so so my
perspective on this was five years ago I
thought about building in exchange I
felt like I had a lot of advantages in
doing that so maybe I should do it but I
also knew and you know I was at Goldman
III understand how this stuff works oh
my god you worked at Goldman Sachs
exactly when it actually wasn't evil you
know when to say that you were or when
people were still like oh my god yeah I
worked at Goldman it was cool to have it
on your resume but the reality is is
that I wasn't passionate about that I
was passionate about solving real
consumer problems I came from the money
transfer space and look the reality is
is that most of the money being made in
crypto today is being made on leverage
and not even just on trading it's being
made on leverage right that's why bit
max is so profitable I think the the
people who are making money in the
crypto space are doing it because they
offer leverage based products and that's
fine that's a product that a certain
percentage of the population that's
active in trading needs
that's not why we exist and we have to
follow our own passion and our own
vision otherwise we're going to fail if
you create a product just because it
makes money right and you don't know
what you're doing and you're not
passionate
you're not willing to really dig deep
and own it you're going to fail and and
so we knew in our heart of hearts that
we were here for a specific reason and
then we know that have even said we also
believe that a lot of those exchange
based services are going to become
commoditized over time I think coinbase
raised their prices this summer that's
an anomaly in my opinion there's so many
exchanges out there that overtime rights
there's going to have to be
consolidation and there's going to have
to be price competition because they all
have the same api's they all have more
or less the same prices they all use the
same stable coins with the exception of
maybe bananas they all offer this wide
breadth of tokens where but not just to
offer anything which is you know a
really interesting perspective but
anyway it becomes a commodity and the
stack has to change and the stack has to
evolve and the stack evolves to look
like a crypto specific banking stack
where in my opinion the crypto becomes
what I call tcp/ip for money so for the
viewers who don't know what that means
is is that when you when you use Netflix
today you're actually using this
networking technology whose complexity
is completely hidden to you as a
consumer there's another way to watch
videos besides the way you're doing it
you can actually write a little code to
create a tcp/ip sockets
you know download individual packets of
information and recreate the video now
that's insane nobody would do that but
you could right so so abre is basically
creating that Netflix like user
experience to hide that complexity of
the crypto to crypto to recreate an
entirely new banking stack that's
relevant for the next generation of
snapchat users of people who don't
understand why you even had Bank
branches in the first place but also
think globally right and so that's how
this is going to evolve in my opinion
over time and the exchanges will have a
place in that system they become more
like the the Goldman's of the world
where they're providing the equivalent
of the repo and and and and those money
market accounts services that we need to
run our crypto banking system so they're
they're laying the foundations for that
today and it's very important abra can't
function without those exchanges OTC
desks and everybody playing their part
in creating a liquid crypto environment
we're simply saying the next evolution
to create a stack for banking that the
retail consumer can use that hides that
complexity just like you don't
understand the complexity as the average
banking customer of what happens in
overnight repo markets and money markets
and how the banks doing fractional
reserve banking and all that great stuff
that has to happen for the existing
system to work right so so long answer
your question but the bottom line is is
that those exchange rails become the
backbone of a next-generation
banking system and Abra wants to be the
retail component to that banking system
and offer the deposit products the
lending products the payment products
with a high-quality mobile user
experience that people are gonna want
globally yeah to me it is you've taken a
strategy where if you own the end-user
right you have a lot of advantages and
it's because they trust your brand
that's right they trust that when I
press this button on the mobile app it
does what I want it to do right my
assets are secure and there's an element
in crypto that we haven't seen it play
out yet
but I think a lot about talk to our
founders which is doing things today
that are short-term focused will hurt
you in the long run right and so gouging
people on fees right all this kind of
stuff because it's all around the brand
and the way people talk about you et
cetera but if you take a really long
term view 20 year view and you say look
we're gonna do things the right way and
we're going to make sure that you know
we have your best interest at heart and
we really align what we do with what you
do what you find is that's not a
marketing message right it's not like
you go you know slap that on on a on a
pitch stack on a billboard and was like
oh yeah of course every company says it
but if you actually do it over a long
period of time you separate yourself
right because every other company
succumbs to doing the things for the
short term around profitability or
revenue or whatever it is and so to me
that is much easier to do when you have
the direct relationship with the user
than it is if you're the behind the
scene rails or you've got an exchange
and Pete and then you are simply just
trying to add more functionality etc and
so it'll be very interesting to see how
this plays out because I don't think a
lot of people are thinking
that way right now but the people who do
have the users well that's a great point
so so we split test products all the
time right so we have users who are
getting new features that other users
don't see we do surveys every day but
it's not the same user base every day
they would get annoying and so we can
mix it up now because and Facebook does
this to the tune of millions of users
right we can't do that we don't have
millions Wheatlands we were experts same
thing but we do it from a small a
slightly smaller perspective well we'll
split test with hundreds or thousands of
users and then deploy relatively quickly
if we think something's working or pull
back if we think things detracted for
those that don't know this this kind of
a be testing or split testing it sounds
like an easy concept right which which
is simply hey bill is a user I'm a user
the product shows you know me experience
a bill experience B and it sees what we
do and they're optimizing for us to
click a button right and if I click the
button and bill doesn't then and enough
people follow my lead and not Bill's
then eventually they ship to 100% of the
user base the button I saw versus the
differentiated button that bill saw but
when I was at Facebook we would do
things like if you just take one button
right or the edges rounded or squared
what's the color
what's the font is the font underlined
is there a shadow is it not right is
there how much space is between the
letters and the top of the button in the
bottom of the button what is the shade
of green and blue and in all of these
variables and there was literally custom
built infrastructure internally where
you can basically put all the variables
in and then because I had so much
traffic they would show all the
different variables and eventually you
know two three days later you would get
okay here's the results right and this
combination of no shadow
you know square-edged this shade of
green with this font this underline you
know whatever gets the most clicks so so
we've even done that level of testing
with our acquisition marketing so when
you are putting a message on a paid
message on social media for example on
Twitter or on Facebook that's how we
have acquired some of our users and
we'll test different messages at the
same time and then those sites are
really good at giving us feedback on
the crew the click-through rates were
getting on different messages and then
we can test not only the click-through
rate but the ultimate sign up rate
meaning what expectations are we setting
at the top of the funnel and how are
those expectations being met at the
bottom of the funnel we actually tested
some advertising in the Philippines
where when we rolled out the stock
features that we had talked about there
and our awareness for bitcoin sales was
so high in the Philippines that as we
were testing the stock features a super
majority of those users weren't using
the app they were downloading to buy
stocks it was reminding them that there
was actually a easy way to buy bitcoin
that's a bit already heard about
so it actually was more of a turned into
a retargeting almost for those of you
who understand marketing it's for a way
to buy a Bitcoin even though it was
advertising by Apple and we were like
what the hell is going on here and then
when we dug in we realized hey these
people actually know a bro already and
you're reminding them that they should
be buying Bitcoin
inadvertently amazing when you were
advertising Apple and and so we said
okay well but that pointed to another
problem which was we have users who are
aware of buying bitcoin who actually
have never bought stocks before who
don't understand buying stocks who don't
even know what the letter is e T and F
mean and so we had start putting more
content and awareness in place on that
when we had assumed that we had to spend
more content awareness on crypto we had
already created enough content and
awareness in the crypto space that we'd
had to go back and do the same thing in
the traditional investing world because
the international user base just didn't
know I actually did a talk in the
Philippines and I think like a hundred
people showed up I would say maybe ten
knew wouldn't ETF was out of 100 and
these were all people who were putting
real money into the app so actually did
a few minutes on what a stock is like
what it means to have an exchange-traded
fund and you know mix it up like in that
regard people were so thankful that you
know we've spent in the meantime there's
guides on stock investing that we had to
create when there's all kinds of
obviously companies have spent millions
right I mean we're not we're not the
first to offer you know that kind of
product and and so it was it was anyway
that type of testing led us to
understand some things about even the
marketing of this that we didn't come to
appreciate it's one of my favorite parts
about building products and growth work
etc is
the human kind of bias and what you
think is gonna work you're always
surprised by what people will leave ibly
so I mean we're always wrong and and the
only way to get right is to get out
there and do it and quickly iterate and
test now it's frustrating because as a
start-up CEO you want to basically spend
a dollar and put a dollar into the
Machine and get exactly X at the other
side of the Machine and you can't expect
that realistically when you're creating
a new product or a new company out of
the gates you have to be willing to test
and iterate and you have to set
expectations that it takes time to do
that but you also need the
macroeconomics to work right so this
year we've had a lot of ups and downs
right so in the crypto space for example
like things spiked for us this summer
and the volumes in exchanges have come
way down like to get I think exchange
trading volume has come down like 7080
percent now we're since the summer since
the summer right and so so we're not an
exchange so we don't see the same exact
generations we do see peaks and valleys
that follow price to some degree and so
so all of that talk on marketing
presupposes that the market itself is
there yeah right you have to market a
product that people do ultimately want
or are going to use yeah and what you're
talking about
is building a company is very scientific
right I think a lot of people just think
oh you create a product throw it out in
the world and like cross your fingers
and it exploded and there's a love
equations if you will that if you really
know what you're doing you focus on
right and so you know for your business
I'm sure that you've got some number in
your head of every time we sign up a
user they're worth X to us over the
lifetime we know right see what those
numbers are today and we talked about
them in our monthly board reports right
yeah and then the goal is okay let's
make up a number write it there we're
gonna make $50 off every user that signs
up over their lifetime and now how do we
go find a new user for less than $50
it's kind of a very easy one right and
literally it's the cost to acquire that
customer versus the lifetime value and
so the part that always cracks me up is
you know there's a lot of people who are
excited bout building companies and all
this stuff and then they come in and and
I really ask him like what is the
science here right like like what are
the important equations how
are you making progress against the
mixed cetera and what I find is that
people just don't know but the second
that they really teaches them or shows
them okay
here's five equations you need to figure
out these and if you show them in a
positive light or you've done the work
to get them where they need to be you'll
raise as much money as you ever want
right and and because you built a
machine and when you build the machine
it does come down to that put a dollar
in you know get a hundred on the back
end a lot of people are interested in
being a part of that it's a big lesson
for wannabe entrepreneurs is study that
kind of the whole funnel process
soup-to-nuts there are so many books out
there about how to how to really address
that address this really well but what
does it mean to acquire a customer what
does it mean to convert a customer how
do you manage the funnel how do you
manage unit economics and if you can't
do that
well you are going to you're never going
to win and as an entrepreneur or if you
don't surround yourself with people that
can do that well so you've done this
well a BIR recently announced that
you've added a ton of new
cryptocurrencies etc talked a little bit
about the the announcement yeah so back
to the point about listening to your
users the number one requested feature
from our users was more cryptocurrencies
just over and over again more cryptic
actually higher limits was was close to
number one but but but more
cryptocurrencies was definitely number
one and you had how many before I don't
know I think was a 30-30 okay so so
we've added another 60 in the US we
actually added 200 to the app we're just
making about 60 of those available to
the US and has to do with how we manage
custody we work with third-party
partners who manage custody in an
exchange of those and so we're beholdin
to their to their rules so for example
the services in the US is available in
like I think 47 states and not in New
York and a couple of other states we're
working on New York right now because
our service providers don't have the bit
license to do that yeah New York is
still frankly somehow someway decided
that they don't want their constituents
to use this it's it makes crazy
former New Yorker and and also an
American but it is what it is we'll
figure it out you do the work to get the
license either ourselves or our partner
we're working with them now and
eventually New Yorkers will have it but
but by and large we try to make every
product available to
every consumer in the world there's 200
new crypto currencies in the app about
60 of those are available in the US and
the rest will be made available to our
international users in the coming coming
days and weeks got it where can people
get the app so you go to a Burt calm
he's the easiest way how did you get
that URL that was hard yes so that's are
you pretty legit yeah it was pretty
legit and and it was hard was was not
paying what they originally wanted I'm
sure where the URL if I if I tell people
what I paid every like how did you do
that because you know it was a company
that actually had bots another company
called abre in a totally different space
and they weren't using the name anymore
so they really didn't want it so I got
kind of lucky
and then actually had some friends at
the company that bought it and I
actually was able to finagle my way in
there to the CEO and kind of have a
heart-to-heart to say hey you don't
really need this come on yeah and and
and by the way I'm trying to solve real
global problems here and you can really
do good by giving this up and and by the
way I'll give you some money but it's
not going to move the needle and you
guys really feel good about you know
having done this and you can go back to
the old employees from the old apperance
say hey look what we're doing with this
this is kind of cool and and and they
agreed what a sales but by the way that
took six months so so to be clear like
it wasn't a four minute conversation so
you ready for this is uh I'm not gonna
say the URL cuz everyone will go bid on
it but there are multiple people who
have bought URLs that they think I'll be
interested in whether they're around
company names or you know whatever they
usually there's some kind of press
article or something they go and buy it
and turn right around an email same day
and say do you want to buy this 5,000
10,000 let me say that my site bought
like pomp XYZ or pop that XYZ and I came
to you and I say hey why don't you buy
from you like literally it recently
happened we invested in a company and
somebody went and bought the URL for
that was like pretty close right and
then came and said you know do you want
to do it and I said no first of all
second of all I hope you linked to a
bunch of stuff so it gives us great SEO
right like basically just you know what
are these people doing but when you
really want need something right it's
worth having the concepts we originally
had go
be calm go Abra we didn't have we still
do we actually own 50 variants to your
point but yeah so there's there's 50
different ways to get to a ber calm we
own them all I'm gonna go buy the 50
first and then give make you buy it so I
don't need at this point so please don't
do that mr. Popple audience and when you
go to a ber calm there'll be a link to
download from the App Store or the Play
Store you just go to the App Store play
store and search forever and you'll find
it and like I said we get lots of
downloads every day and so you know
please come join the family where'd the
name come from so that was a tough one I
went through a multi-month process
it's like naming a child it is like
naming a child as meant this was harder
I actually came up with the names of my
three boys much faster that was my role
I actually named them as since I didn't
have to give birth to them but both
processes both processes took multiple
months yeah yeah my ex was gracious and
letting me letting me name the kids
anyway another story another day Abra
was tough so I loved the member I was
focused on money transfer remittances I
had this idea for a better remittance
app a br a that works that works that
works really well and my at the time my
middle son was really into magic he was
attic artistry you ever see people be
able to do like were they shuffle cards
and they can actually hold like cards
eight different ways in their hands at
the same time he could do that at like
ten all right cuz he's 16 now or
seventeen but but he was you know this
is five years ago when I named the
company and it was like abracadabra
right so there was a magical component
to that something he's gonna love that
and so between the better remittance app
the idea of magic and the synthetic
currency to me was very much like magic
it was very simple
I loved the idea of having a one one
syllable word that will work in multiple
countries right that it works in in an
arabic-speaking country in a Latin
speaking country and you know Germanic
speaking countries that's very hard to I
went through that at Netscape when we
would launch new products that people
couldn't say the product because we had
a lot of people who were very you know
Mountain View centric right not even
East Bay centric right and then I'd go
to Timbuktu and they'd be like they
couldn't say the product name and so we
did an even testing of that where I
would actually
call up friends who I knew spoke a
foreign language and sake do me a favor
say abre and I would listen to them say
Avril all right thank you and I hang up
Bill's crazy I did now exactly so
panavia company is really hard and the
more passionate about it you are the
harder it is because the closer to it
you are and so we had a lot of debates
about it I was on the fence myself there
was other names I don't even remember
them now which which is very telling but
one of my co-founders reminded me that
there were other names that we were on
the fence about change history man Avril
was the name from day one and you're
ready to go with it we have a holding
company that owns the shares and it's
called Plutus financial Plutus is the
Greek god of wealth and and so I wanted
to hold it I knew that that would never
be a consumer name but I had to I had to
call the company something and so we
just we just kept it in place because it
was easier not to change we may change
it to Amber later but if you look at our
Terms of Service it actually says your
terms of service are with Plutus
financial which is actually an
interesting name in and of itself I love
that the Greek god of well but a brazeau
is the right product day for us I love
it alright man listen I really
appreciate you coming and doing this
you've got a very unique perspective and
I think you've been around obviously for
a very long time so the experience is is
well appreciated and I'll have to do
this again sometime in the future you'll
have to come back for time number three
I want to be the first person to be on
for a third time so alright don't give
that up deal alright man
pleasure to be here thanks for having me
absolutely alright